on a frozen ocean
many miles from land
a mother polar bear teaches her cubs to
survive in one of the harshest
environments on earth
these extraordinary bears spend every
winter on a continent of ice
[Music]
now we reveal the secret lives of polar
bears
[Music]
and how they rule
over their icy kingdom
a polar bear could kill a man with one
swipe of his paw
but these hungry teenage males
are just killing time
waiting for the big freeze
in canada's frozen north
hundreds of polar bears are following an
age-old migration route
an annual spectacle played out on the
shores of hudson bay
over thousands of years they've been
instinctively drawn to the area of the
bay where the waters freeze first
providing the earliest access to the
frozen sea
and their natural hunting ground
these massive creatures haven't eaten in
months
this is going to build
out into the bay and it'll be just like
a big freeway for the bears to go out
and conceal
[Music]
for more than 40 years legendary polar
bear guy dennis campari has been
tracking the arctic's polar bear
population
on land sea
and ice
i seen all the range of emotions these
animals go through
and i could connect with every emotion
that they showed me
it's a world few humans ever see
but dennis has spent a lifetime in the
secret world of polar bears
they're part of my identity they're part
of who i am
[Music]
dennis has followed and friended
countless individual bears from the time
they were cubs
but years ago he made a close connection
with a bold young male
who came looking for
him come across him when he was 11
months old
he did something no other bear ever did
is that he broke away from his mother
and come over to where i was
so i played a little game with him where
i ducked down and he couldn't see me
anymore so what he did he got on his
hind legs and kind of walked backwards
to see if he could see me over the top
they said oh he looks like a little
dancer so he called him dancer
five or six years after that i had my
own little buggy i woke up in the
morning and all of a sudden
the whole buggy went whoop this shuck oh
my lord
so i went to the window and there was a
huge polar bear there
come here come on
come on
yeah it's me
he looked at him and he looked at me as
soon as he seen me
he stood up and started dancing like it
was dancer he found me after all those
years
[Music]
man so that would kind of
give my heart an old tickle there and uh
so that whole relationship
started all over again
come and see me
for the next five or six years after
that he'd come back and find me wherever
i was
you know we visited until the bay froze
over and the way he went
that's dancer
[Music]
these days dancer is like a lot of
hudson bay polar bears
[Music]
missing in action
dennis estimates about a 20 drop in the
local bear population
but they come back to the bay every year
waiting for it to freeze
[Music]
fresh water in the churchill river
freezes before salt water in the bay
the ice field spreads from here
[Music]
at the height of winter reaching half a
million square miles
an ice continent the size of france
the early hard freeze has always been
reliable
until now
[Applause]
it took us a long time here on a local
level to understand climate change
up until five or six years ago we could
just about predict the weather
the bears could too
that's why they're here
but the planet's throwing them a
curveball
the wind would shift blow from the north
it would stay in that direction right
till march and april
but now that doesn't work anymore
we just can't tell what's going to
happen tomorrow we don't know if the ice
is going to be thick enough to travel on
the ice is the bear's safe haven and
hunting ground
[Music]
but the waters are freezing later now
and melting sooner
giving them less time each winter to
bulk up for the long lean summer on land
the last six years
we've noticed an absence of big males we
where the hell are they
[Music]
you know are they still out there
you know it's a population in serious
trouble and uh you know mom and cubs
what are the mom and cubs doing out
there the dead winter how are they
surviving
with winter on its way
dennis is determined to find out
he's preparing for one last epic
expedition
to track these bears through an entire
year of their lives
to see for himself how a changing world
is impacting the polar bears of hudson
bay
i don't know all of them will ever be
answered but i'll get some information
out of it so that's this is kind of like
my final quest before i
you know give it up
but winter's still a waiting game for
these bears
apex predators that haven't had a real
meal in months
and won't until they get back on the ice
to hunt seals
[Music]
on solid ground the largest land
predators on the planet
are reduced to scavengers
[Music]
every calorie counts
for now tiny fish trapped in the early
ice are the best this bear can do
[Music]
an arctic fox also smells the fish
doesn't stand a chance
the clock is ticking for all these bears
forcing some to take big risks
a desperate polar mom and her cubs can't
wait for a more solid freeze
the ice is barely holding them up
searching for food
they find only danger on the treacherous
shoreline
there's also a hungry male lurking in
the rolling ice floes
but he isn't looking to mate
he's hunting her cubs
she's gonna have a hard time keeping the
cub safe from that guy
on canada's arctic coast
a polar mom leads her cubs onto unstable
ice in search of food
she hasn't eaten in months
there's a mother and two cubs walking
precariously on that ice
[Music]
a huge male is also hungry
and stalking her cubs
we're hungry this time of the year
polar bears are known to eat their own
she's gonna have a hard time keeping her
cub safe from that guy
plus
not going through the ice
[Music]
protecting her cubs puts them all at
risk
so it's a pretty crazy situation going
on over there
[Music]
but the unstable ice is even too much
for the male
the mom and cubs escape
[Music]
[Music]
finally frigid winds sweep out of the
north
[Music]
temperatures plummet
almost overnight
solid ice starts spreading out into
hudson bay
[Music]
this is the moment the bears have been
waiting for since last spring
[Music]
but just as the ice beckons
and hundreds of bears march onto the
frozen bay
a pregnant female heads off in the
opposite direction
on an even more urgent mission
[Music]
and another age-old migration
[Music]
shield track 50 miles inland
but our mom knows exactly where she's
going
back to her ancestral birthing dens
[Music]
she'll endure one of the longest fasts
in the animal kingdom
eight months without a real meal
but her keen sense of smell detects a
chance at a few last critical calories
before entering the den
arctic foxes can kill enough lemmings
hiding in the snow
to stockpile leftovers for later
[Music]
the foxes make a futile attempt to
protect their stash
[Music]
but they're fighting way above their
weight class
10 pound canines are no match for a 600
pound bear
[Music]
[Music]
this is a mysterious magical time for
polar bears
often finding dens that go back
generations
dug into the permafrost
they're custom fit to her dimensions
[Music]
eight feet long and only three feet high
carved to wrap around her with no room
to move around
[Music]
so
[Music]
once she enters the den
she won't reappear for more than three
months
[Music]
as winter
[Music]
descends dennis campare launches his own
search for a polar bear birthing den
[Music]
his goal
to witness the miracle of a polar mom
emerging after months of isolation
followed by her newborn cubs
then track their epic journey back to
the ice in hudson bay
my quest now is to observe these animals
during the whole 12 months of the year
the whole year cycle for them and that
would make
my journey with these animals complete
dennis is completely exposed in one of
the most inhospitable climates on earth
at a bone-chilling 40 below
a breakdown on the tundra could be
catastrophic
[Music]
along the way the veteran polar bear
guide spies another age-old migration
oh my lord
[Music]
one of the most massive in the natural
world
thousand caribou crossing the ice
weather tough they're tough this time of
the year
what a sight
with just a few hours of daylight
remaining
dennis has to keep moving
[Music]
his destination
an old trapper shack
base camp for a search for a polar bear
birthing den
polar bear guy dennis campari is riding
into a frozen wilderness
on a journey to determine how the bears
of hudson bay are coping in a changing
world
but now
he needs to find shelter before
nightfall
an old trapper shack will be his base of
operations
in his search for a polar bear birthing
den
somewhere in the vast arctic expanse
hmm
[Music]
dennis now has to explore this
featureless world to find signs that an
isolated snow drift conceals a birthing
den
the temporary home for a mom with cubs
just a few months old
that still haven't seen the
sun it's a seemingly impossible task
if you're looking for a den that's never
been opened up or been broached for the
first time it's difficult as hell
you can look and look and look and take
your days and days and days
it really is like finding a needle in
the haystack out there such a huge area
it takes a lifetime of experience to
even suspect he's found the birthing
then
a heat-sensitive camera will detect
anything alive under all that snow
ah
modern technology confirms the old
tracker's gut instincts
look at that
i got a heat trace coming out of that
hole
there's got to be a den
it's a perfect place for a den
this is the spot this is where the new
pool of our lives start right here
for the bears inside
the snow provides both camouflage and
insulation
[Music]
it's quite comfy and it's well insulated
you know the newborns are they're not
that big you know i mean 12 16 ounces
could be 40 50 below outside and they're
pretty snug within this nice thick
covering of snow
[Music]
for dennis
it's a different story
he settles in
exposed to some of the harshest weather
on the planet
now it's just a waiting game see how
long it's going to take for them to pop
out
the windchill drops to 40 below
without proper winter gear a human would
die out here in minutes
but it's a vigil dennis is determined to
maintain
a mom won't leave the den until her
newborn is strong enough to face
nature's most brutal conditions
[Music]
far from dennis on the tundra
another mom leads her one year world cup
onto the pack ice in hudson bay
for the most critical lesson any polar
bear can learn
hunting ringed seals
even an expert hunter has to play the
percentages
[Applause]
[Music]
ring seals a polar bear's primary prey
don't make it easy
they can stay submerged in icy water for
45 minutes
but like any mammal
eventually they have to come up for air
that's a bear's window of opportunity
[Music]
so seals create a network of breathing
holes spread out across the ice
to keep the bears guessing where they
may surface
[Music]
[Music]
it's day 10 of dennis's vigil
[Music]
but from deep inside there are
indications life is beginning to stir
if you look between the trees over there
you'll see how the snow is disturbed and
it's kind of roughed up a bit
you know if you look closer you can see
start of a hole
and if you look into that hole you see a
polar bear a mother full of air
hopefully with cubs
[Music]
settled into a snow bank nearby
all dennis can do is continue to watch
and wait
oh man
[Music]
amazing
[Laughter]
this might be it
there's something in there so it got to
be the mum
after 10 long days camped outside a
polar bear birthing den
dennis campari is beginning to see signs
of life buried in the snow
i'm sure she's anxious to get out you
know her cubs are growing and growing
every day so that little space she
occupies is getting smaller and smaller
creatures that will grow to be eight
feet tall and weigh more than a thousand
pounds
begin life no more than a foot long
their weight measured in ounces
[Music]
oh yeah
oh man
amazing
the cubs grow to about 25 pounds before
mom decides they're ready to venture out
into the world for the first time
oh my look at that
[Music]
that's amazing
after three months trapped in that ice
cave
she emerges first
to see if the coast is clear
and take a long awaited snow bath
[Music]
probably hasn't eaten
since july so she's pretty hungry at
this point
leveling off her fat reserves
despite a 30 drop in body fat
she's comfortable at 40 below
but it's still too cold for newborns
she won't allow the cubs out right away
it'll be a day or two before the cubs
will come out
we still don't know how many
cubs she has
we know she has cubs obviously but we
don't know how many
one would be nice two would be great
three would be amazing
as the sun sets
dennis knows no mom would bring her cubs
out into an arctic night
darkness descends
temperatures plummet
as the cold produces the arctic's
signature night spectacle
[Music]
nature's psychedelic light show
blazing across the northern sky
an elder told me
if you watch the northern lights for
more than 10 seconds there to come down
and grab you
take you up in the sky and nobody will
ever see you again
i still find myself counting when i look
up at the northern lights
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
only -22 today
[Music]
the sun is out and the wind has dropped
that's a good indication that mom's
going to poke her head out of the den
and have a look around and see what's
going on
more sun and less wind could be just
what the mom's been waiting for
dennis has a hunch this could be the day
he's traveled so far
and waited so long
to see
[Music]
[Music]
dennis campari has been waiting in
windchill dropping to 40 below
[Music]
for the moment new polar bear cubs
emerge into one of the harshest
environments on earth
the new mom's been checking conditions
every day to make sure they're safe for
her cubs to greet the world for the
first time
she never brings the cubs out on their
first two or three days they don't show
up you know until a few days later
today could be the day dennis and mom
have been waiting for
[Music]
[Music]
man
amazing
it's a new life
two beautiful young cubs
you know there's there's hope when you
see animals like this
[Music]
nothing much in the animal world that
you know makes your heart beat a bit
more than
what i'm looking at now it's pretty
incredible stuff
[Music]
over the next few weeks the family will
stay close to the den
mom keeps them safe and well fed
she'll be their sole source of
nourishment for the first four months of
their lives
the fat content in the milk i said like
over 30 percent so it's rich as hell and
the cubs just gobble enough and just
grow and grow and grow
[Music]
a mother polar bear is is probably one
of the strongest
mothers going
you know everything she has is invested
in these newborns so
she's an incredible mother for sure
desperately hungry after months without
food
she's carefully monitoring her cubs
to determine when they'll be ready for a
marathon 50-mile trek to the bay
where she can finally hunt for food
again
[Music]
[Music]
days pass
[Music]
the cubs have a lot of growing and
learning to do to survive in the arctic
[Music]
their antics serve as a workout
building muscle for the long walk to
hudson bay
[Music]
it's nothing but play to them but of
course to mom what's happening is
they're building up their stamina and
their strengths
for this crazy trek they have to take to
get out to the
hudson bay to hunt seal
the cubs have no experience of the
dangers all around them
unfortunately
50
of cubs of the year don't make it
mom is always standing guard
we can't see what she does it's very
subtle
you know they could play and be around
functions and this and that and
whatever signal the mother gives they
just
snap back right in line and listen to
every command
they have to pay close attention to the
mom because
she's the one that's going to keep him
alive
today
polar mom smells trouble
[Music]
she's not the only predator around
so we've seen a wolverine trendling
across her horizon there
the wolverine were known to take down
polar bear cubs so it's
it's a bit troublesome
she raises the alert level
her cubs
could be in serious danger
[Music]
like the new mom
veteran polar bear tracker dennis
campari is also on guard duty when the
cubs are outside at play in the snow
[Music]
you know they're just exploring their
new world and
the idea for
now is just let them
run around and
get some stamina
[Music]
but mom smells danger
a wolverine
they're fierce ruthless predators
this is a flanking maneuver
designed to disguise plans for a sneak
attack
wolverines are capable of taking down
much larger prey
including caribou
even moose
[Music]
the cubs are in danger
it takes two and a half years to teach
these cubs everything they need to know
to survive on their own and you know
that's been mum's goal since day one
they make it back to the safety of the
damn
[Music]
the area around the den is a playground
[Music]
the polar mom is eager for them to put
on weight and add muscle
[Music]
but with the cubs constantly feeding
she's at a tipping point
their mother has not had anything
significantly to eat in the last eight
months
so she's pretty hungry at this point
leveling off her fat reserves
if she waits much longer to leave the
den
she won't be able to feed them
the biggest thing these young cubs have
to
overcome is starvation
her resources are being dwindled
and if she doesn't have any milk to feed
these young ends before they have a
feast of
seal
they can starve
mom needs to get moving
the nearest seal kill is more than 50
miles away
on her own she could reach the bay in a
few days
[Music]
with her cubs in tow
it will take weeks
[Music]
once mom figures
that her youngans are ready to go on
this long trek
she gives them some kind of sickle
finally she makes the call
then the horseplay stops
it's time to get serious now and and the
little cops they just snap right in line
it's time to go
the challenges ahead are formidable
after the long march to the pack ice
they'll have only a few short months for
mom to replenish 30 of her body weight
and for the cubs to grow strong enough
for the marathon swim back to land in
the spring
[Music]
in the kingdom of the polar bears life's
about to get very real very quickly
as they take their first steps on an
epic journey
[Music]
you